6 22 here it is a Wednesday morning
providing children in need with clothes
is the mission of clothing Clark County
and joining us this morning the
nonprofits founder May Kane thank you
for joining us and also saucy from we're
a Thai because we're going to talk about
a fundraiser for the organization thank
you both for coming in this morning
thank you we'll get to the food in a
second I promise you the first uh May
let's talk about the non-profit clothing
Clark County what it does here in the
community thank you so much so our
mission is to provide students with
clothes backpacks and shoes by bringing
awareness to Title 1 students here in
Clark County we like for them to be able
to focus on their education and not what
they don't have what's the need in the
community a lot of nonprofits help in
this regard but you know you're focused
on the clothing aspect in particular
what is the need right now yeah we also
focus on patient as well so we do this
awesome incentive program where when you
reach your goals you get rewarded and
actually surprised with brand new shoes
so what we have done in the past is
surprise classrooms when they reach
their goals as a group with brand new
shoes and brand new clothes and it's
awesome because when you walk in you
have all these bags with all their names
on it so it's their sizes it's the
colors that they like the brands that
they like and you walk in you're like
congratulations we heard that someone
was doing awesome in class and his
classroom's been killing it and here are
some new shoes for you guys and you're
in your own experience we were talking
about of of what it does for a student
to get those new clothes during the
school year or just even out of school
the the feeling it brings them is so
positive it is it's confidence it's fun
it's exciting I think about it growing
up anytime got a pair of anything that
was new whether it's shoes clothes a
brush even today to this day I'm like
wow I got a new hair tie like it's
exciting it's fun and you feel great and
students deserve to feel awesome when
they go to school and feel confident so
they can just feel focus on their
education on math English whatever it
may be so sassy is here from wear a Thai
that's why all the food is here and
we're a Thai is involved in trying to
help this non-profit tell us about how
the restaurant is involved in trying to
do good here
um we love to support our community and
um
May she's tired she loved Thai food
don't we all yeah and there's a and
there's a luncheon that you guys are
hosting yeah we're hosting lunch from 11
30 yes okay and and if people are
interested in going to the luncheon to
support the non-profit and support we
are a Thai which a lot of us in the in
the valley already know when is the
luncheon and how can they take part the
luncheon is next Tuesday is from 11 30
to 2 30 and it's at we are a type at the
newest location which is stunning yeah
and you can RSVP by either shooting a
text or a phone call at
702-845-1716 and seats are limited but
you can pay at the door as well
excellent it's a great organization and
you're online as well I assume with your
nonprofit yes I am at
www.clothingclarkecounty.org excellent
well this food is very delicious you can
enjoy some of this that we're tied down
in the southwest Valley what rainbow and
Warm Springs I think you were saying
right and help a good Community
organization as well there are the
details on your screen you can RSVP we
were tied down there uh May and Saucy
Thank you very much for coming in this
morning it's a great organization great
restaurant as well and we're going to
Chow Down to the commercial break if
that's okay what do you say yes we
brought Forks we brought Forks